it's time for some q a or should i say
druin a it's the beauty edition we
answered some of our vfs most burning
beauty questions tackling everything
from skin care
to how to rock the latest makeup trends
i mean this
is my lane let's take a look first up
we have amanda amanda what's your
question
so i love a colorful eye trend and i'm
a remote kindergarten teacher so i am
online
all the time and i don't want to look
too crazy with too much color
so how can i add a pop of color to my
look
first of all that's a fantastic question
second of all my first instinct is to
say
try a colored eyeliner because
it's going to be easy to apply you have
so much more control over a pencil than
you know
i still get intimidated by eyeshadow and
creating
that smokey eye or do i want the color
to be brought down to the bottom do i go
all the way to the brow where am i
finishing do the corners
so eyeshadow is a big league
ticket you know for makeup whereas the
liner
you can just have a lot of control and
it'll be more
minimalist so i feel like it's a fun
toes
in for color i
think that's awesome i think that you're
right it's way easier to control
sometimes they do my eye shadow and it's
like
in my eyebrows and i'm like what is
happening my kids would be like what's
that green stuff on your eyes
i think the liner is a great idea yeah
well it's like
the possibilities are almost too endless
with eyeshadow
whereas eyeliner has just more control
do you have a favorite makeup brand
um a favorite makeup brand i love
mac i absolutely love mac oh well
they have the most incredible colors
with their pencils so go in get
some that feel like the toes in and
because it's liner
go for something bold as well maybe get
two different colors one that's a little
tamer and a little more daytime and one
that's a little more like
i'm going all in right well thank you
amanda i hope that
helped thank you helped so much i'm
excited
okay next up is ro
what's your question hey true girl
hi okay hi okay so
every morning i do my makeup and by two
o'clock
i have a shiny forehead like shiny like
a mirror shiny
how can i combat oily skin
that's interesting too like i have this
hormonal goatee thing happening
on my face so i completely understand
when it can happen like
you have to take care of like a certain
area and it's not the whole face but
it's
particular i would invest in
a pack of blotting papers or rice papers
i love the rice papers if you don't have
one on hand i recommend
even toilet paper or a tissue the
blotting
and and dabbing for me is first and
foremost
to almost like stains extract
everything that's on the surface or
underneath
and then apply because anything you
apply
will stick to the sweat and move around
and it's just not going to look good
well thank you i'm going to give me some
rice paper and blot away
oh ro will you let us know how that's
going for you
i sure will because if it doesn't work
and you don't like it we'll go on to the
next idea
okay okay sounds good perfect thank you
ro
thank you drew okay mariana where
are you and what's your question
hey drew i'm up here in toronto today um
my question is these dark circles
no matter how much concealer i apply
these dark circles give away the fact
that i've been up all night
binge watching my favorite tv show um
what can i do to like mask that fact and
make it look like i've had eight hours
of sleep
i actually have a tip because i
uh went into a movie adam sandler
kindly asked me to partner up again for
our third film called blended and i had
just had my daughter olive
six months before and needless to say a
new baby
are up all night and i looked like the
[ __ ] keeper and i felt like that too
so what i found was that
um i found a white pigmented
formula so i'm going to recommend a few
brands one is rms that i really love
and i'll look at some other brands as
well that might provide
the right kind of it has to have a
little mica
a little translucent so what i do is i
put a little white
concealer under my eye concealer so the
white reflects
out like light and it brings it covers
the purple and the blue
and helps create a better springboard
for the concealer to work on
great tip so there is a great rms
palette that we're going to make sure
you get
and i will think of some other brands
because there's not a ton on the market
i actually made a palette for flower
beauty called hollywood secret
and we just didn't have the right
messaging for it and it didn't really
work but
i'm going to bring it back because it's
something i feel really strongly about
and it works
i'm looking forward to that thank you
thank you so much drew
thank you for your questions i love this
thank you
so much you guys and might i add you're
all
so incredibly beautiful um
all right well i want to make sure to
help all your
ladies beauty dreams come true and i'm
going to send each one of you
a hundred dollar gift card to flower
beauty and
you'll be able to find some of the
things that we discussed
today but i'm also very happy to go out
and get you the exact products from
these companies
also that i feel are the necessary first
steps to
try thank you
please keep sending in your questions i
love hearing from you and more
importantly
i want to see if we can make you happy